that you may have been back in that era
where did you
hello where did you get that
now then young ladies and young
gentlemen i'd like you to learn this
song with me
do you all know the words
a proper oh i should like to have one
just
the same as that there i go they shut
out
where did you get that did you
get my hands
but i should like to have one just the
same as dance
whenever i could they shout out
oh
one side of your body like that and you
can split that up and go
rainbow rainbow smile smile
or you can do butterflies like that so
you put the hand to right with
in front of the other hand okay so
you can practice
oh
oh
i suppose you're all here to see the
punching judy show aren't
the you of the show the man you've all
been waiting for
give him a nice big clap and a nice
picture it's
mr punch
everybody
oh that was very good do you know the
way you all shouted
yes i have thought mr punch was really
there
oh i say give me that stick you i'll
teach you to be mean to me and my baby
take that
oh i see my mother was right
i never should have married him mr puns
give me that stick
what i said give it to me all right
help help boys and girls call from the
police man
call for the police
pre-fabricated hospitals for soldiers
many lives take florence nightingale
with bees
oh
bye